over the past week we've been focusing
on afghanistan as the taliban mark one
year since their return to power the
rulers in afghanistan are facing an
ongoing insurgency from an affiliate of
isis there and they are responding with
an effort to build a new police force
mts taeyab is in kabul forest that's
afghanistan's capital to show us how it
is working out mti's good morning it's
one thing to seize power quite another
to wield it would you would you find out
hey tony good to talk to you and you're
absolutely right as the taliban's grip
on afghanistan only tightens the former
insurgents now turned rulers have to
figure out how to serve and protect in
cities and towns they used to attack
this is the new face of policing in the
taliban's afghanistan former insurgents
turned police officers whose job now is
to serve and protect most have traded in
the traditional clothing they once were
on the battlefield for these new fitted
uniforms and caps but it's going to take
a lot more than uniforms to turn former
taliban fighters into officers of the
law
we went on a ride-along with these
recruits who confessed they aren't
finding their new jobs easy as the
dalbaugh tries to remake its fighters
into a professional police force it's
facing its own challenge from the afghan
affiliate of isis known as isis k
according to the un's mission in
afghanistan this past month is the
deadliest the country has seen since the
taliban's takeover one year ago
just last week a suicide bombing at this
mosque in kabul killed 21 people
including the imam
although no group has yet claimed
responsibility it follows a similar
pattern including an attack a week
earlier claimed by isis k which killed
another high-profile cleric who had
close ties to the taliban
isis k first emerged in 2015. it's
linked to the original islamic state
branch in iraq and syria but is made up
mainly of defectors from the afghan and
pakistani taliban you don't see those
groups as extreme enough
last year in the final days of the us's
chaotic withdrawal from afghanistan a
lone suicide bomber detonated a device
that killed 13 u.s service members and
at least 170 afghans at kabul airport an
attack claimed by isis k today the now
infamous abbey gate where the bomb went
off is quiet but signs of the horrors
that happened here still remain
it's hard to imagine one year ago this
was the scene of such desperation as
afghans tried to flee the country and
the taliban and all we really have left
to remind us of their desperation to
flee
is fragments of their clothing
caught in this barbed wire
the un says isis k has now expanded into
almost all of afghanistan's provinces
[Music]
khalid zadran who fought for years as an
insurgent is now the main spokesman for
the taliban's kabul police the afghan
affiliate of isis known as isis k must
be a concern for you though
no because they don't pose a significant
threat and that they cannot take over
our country he says but they do target
innocent people and we will try to
prevent such attacks to keep our country
safe
for now isis k has nowhere near the
numbers of the taliban and we haven't
detected any sort of meaningful support
amongst afghans for isis k but the group
has been able to carry out horrific
attacks targeting people who've already
suffered
so so much vlad
nts in afghanistan where he's been doing
some phenomenal reporting mts thank you
so much on today's cbs morning's podcast
mtis will share what it's been like
reporting from afghanistan as the
country marks one year since the u.s
withdrawal